as I'm watching you in that clip there
is a little bit of some Hugh Grant in
your voice and I'm only catching it now
or is it that I'm projecting I I think
there probably is Tiny bits of it I mean
I I worked with them when I was 11 so it
was quite an influential time I guess in
my life and and you know you've worked
with you he's so charming and funny and
his mannerisms are so distinct that they
probably have
subconsciously perforated me a little
bit he was the best yes okay someone
else you're working with who is a legend
and an icon of just Epic Proportions
Nicholas Cage oh yeah and you did the
weatherman with him I did yeah back in
the day and I've been watching you guys
in your junkets talk about then and now
yeah
um what is he like because I used to
know him back in like the old Club days
I used to like I wish I had more stories
from the old Club days because
occasionally I get a glimpse of like the
wild days of Nick Cage and I'm like whoa
this is because he now he's he's very
diligent with the work he I mean and it
doesn't get better for me in this movie
it's Nick Cage as Dracula so it doesn't
get more iconic than those two combined
really
like he's he's he's just he's got it he
just keeps ascending he is one of the
most intriguing
figures I think that has ever been in
this industry oh completely his
dedication and also where he draws
inspiration from particularly for this
this Dracula role is so fun to be on set
with and witness it I I just felt very
lucky every day to be like a front row
seat to Nicholas Cage yeah so I had a
brilliant which makes it all the more
delicious yeah speaking of delicious did
you anticipate the menu being such a hit
I mean like really it's critically
acclaimed it did so well in movie
theaters
I never you never expect anything to be
a hit you hope that people will like it
obviously um but with that I knew I knew
that the script was good and felt
original and then on set I could see all
the wonderful performances that everyone
was giving and particularly Rafe and
Anya and everyone and then and then also
Mark our director was so talented from
succession which I love so it was like
you know all the pieces seem to be have
potential but you never know like you
know it's like we're all if it was a
science then every movie everyone ever
made would be brilliant but it's not
you'd be Marvel is true that when you
were a kid you went on an audition
and you ate cake no I had to pretend to
eat this was like my first audition
um when I was five for a film they said
sit under a table and pretend to eat
cake and I was like well that is so easy
and so I did that and I got the part and
I was like and and so I think eating and
acting has always been synonymous for me
since then probably why I end up doing
like the menu and eating bugs in
Renfield and all this sort of stuff
because it's like going to work is just
eating for me well it's funny that you
would say eating bugs because it's true
you've been making the rounds and
everybody is having you eat bugs and can
I stay on that Trend and eat bugs with
you yeah yeah and I heard you're
intrigued by Pizza salad hashtag Pizza
salad yes I've heard about this so one
of my things when I first came to
America working in America and I was
like your salads are very unsalady like
how because it was just like bacon an
egg and cheese there was more of that
than there was leaves oh yeah I was like
it's delicious I'm not complaining I
like I like how you've run with with
salad and just decided you know what
we'll call it a salad but essentially
it's just all the yummy stuff that we
want from somewhere else well let's go
eat bugs and pizza salad and margaritas
thank you
[Music]